MARK MANDEL: Hi, and
welcome to episode
number 117 of the weekly
Google Cloud Platform Podcast.
I'm Mark Mandel, and I'm here
with my colleague, Melanie
Warrick.
Melanie, how are
you doing today?
MELANIE WARRICK: I'm great.
MARK MANDEL: Thanks for joining
me for yet another week.
MELANIE WARRICK: And still
in the actual studio.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
you're still actually
in the studio,
though I know you've
been running around a bit.
We have, I think, one
of your favorite people.
MELANIE WARRICK: I know.
I am super thrilled.
Our interview this week
is with Dr. Fei-Fei Li,
who is the chief scientist
of AI/ML, Machine Learning,
at Google Cloud.
She's a visionary in this space.
And it was incredible to be
able to have her come on.
So I'm looking forward
to that interview,
sharing that with the public.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
it was really great
sitting there and
listening and understanding
at least about a quarter of it.
MELANIE WARRICK: You hung
in there really well.
MARK MANDEL: Thanks.
MELANIE WARRICK:
You did a good job.
As always, we start with
our cool things of the week
and then we end with a question.
And so for this
week, the question
is actually, if you want
to learn about machine
learning, what are some.
And we'll list a couple of
options for you to explore.
But before we get
into that, let's
talk about the cool
things of the week.
One of the cool
things of the week
is that there's this
new nonprofit that
was started called Partnerships
on Artificial Intelligence.
And Terah Lyons, who's new as
a founding executive director
of this group, is basically
leading this group
to help ensure AI
is applied in ways
that benefit people in society.
To quote her, she
said, "We will have
to work very hard to make it
so that the benefits of what
we are creating are
broadly distributed
and that technologies
like AI are applied
to solve grand challenges
instead of being wielded
exclusively by privilege and
narrow special interests."
What's interesting about this
is that this specific nonprofit
was pulled together by Apple,
Amazon, DeepMind, us, Google,
Facebook, Microsoft, IBM.
And they've got board members
that have representatives
from universities,
foundations, and groups
like the American
Civil Liberties Union.
So it's a really interesting
organization that's come about
and is pushing for AI
ethics, to kind of throw back
to our machine learning
bias and fairness
discussion a few weeks back.
So that's one cool thing.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
I am going to mention
something that actually I
think I've been wanting
for a really long time.
So if you use Cloud Data
Store, fully managed
export and import
with Cloud Data Store
is now generally available.
If you've ever used this
tool, probably for a long time
you will remember the old
admin tool that was existed.
It was sort of a cron
job [INAUDIBLE] of jobs.
It wasn't the best experience
one could possibly have had.
I'll put it that way.
No, it was good.
It did the job.
But this tool looks to
be a whole lot better.
You'll have a newer API.
There's integration with IM.
And previously, like, you were
looking at much longer times
for doing backups.
These backups should be
happening a whole lot
faster as well.
So if you want to
check it out, I'll
have a link in the
show notes to show
through how you can
export and import entities
through the documentation.
It looks like a much
nicer and easier process
than what we previously had.
So I'm super happy about that.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes.
And there's also a
blog post out there
on how Color, the company,
uses the new Variant Transforms
tool for breakthrough clinical
data science with BigQuery.
This is interesting from a
genomics perspective for those
out there who are in that space.
So Color is a health
services company
that offers affordable and
accessible genetic testing,
and they wanted to be
able to do more heavy data
mining on the data that they
have to better understand
their client DNA.
So variance is a popular
task in genomic analysis,
and it's basically identifying
a variant of a specific genome
from some reference genome.
And so BigQuery was
something that they
went with because
apparently it's
very mature in
terms of its ability
to handle the type of
data sets that they're
working with because it's
fully managed data warehouse
and it has strong genomic
data import mechanism.
And the Variant Transforms
is a recently released tool
that's basically-- and
it's an open source tool.
It's out on GitHub.
And we'll have a link.
But it's basically
able to handle
massive amounts of genomic
data directly and load it
into BigQuery for you.
And it works with Data Store,
too, as far as I understand.
But yeah, we'll post that
out there for you guys.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
Lastly, one of our
teammates, Eric Schmidt--
not that Eric Schmidt.
Different Eric Schmidt.
Developer Advocate Eric Schmidt.
MELANIE WARRICK: Exactly.
MARK MANDEL: I feel, I feel very
sorry for him for that reason.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Although, in some ways
it could probably
be a plus, too.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
pros and cons, right?
Just pros and cons.
MELANIE WARRICK: Maybe he
gets into places better.
MARK MANDEL: Maybe he does.
Google Cloud and NCAA team
up for a unique March Madness
competition hosted on Kaggle.
I believe that's basketball.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes,
that is basketball.
You and I both are not
sports people, apparently.
Anyways, yes.
And this is their fifth
annual one that they've done,
where you're building
up models to predict
and I guess build out
your March Madness.
So that was launched
actually last week
and closes March 15 in terms
of submitting your predictions
and submitting your model.
MARK MANDEL: And there's
a $100,000 prize pool.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Yes, prize pool.
And to note that that
is split out over--
I think first place is $25,000,
second place is $15,000,
and third place is
$10,000, which, actually,
when you think about it,
doesn't really add up.
So I wonder where the
rest of the money goes.
But anyways--
MARK MANDEL: It's fine.
It works out.
MELANIE WARRICK: It's fine.
It's something like that.
So yeah, you should
check it out.
We'll put the link in there if
you are a big basketball fan
and also love data.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Awesome.
All right, well why don't we
go chat with Dr. Fei-Fei Li?
MELANIE WARRICK:
So today's podcast
we're excited to have join
us Dr. Fei-Fei Li, who
is our chief scientist of
AI and ML for Google Cloud,
and she is the
Associate Professor
in the computer science
department at Stanford,
who's currently on sabbatical.
So welcome.
FEI-FEI LI: Thank you.
MELANIE WARRICK: And you
know, before we get started,
we know about your
background, but we
would like to have you tell
in your own words who you are
and what you do.
FEI-FEI LI: I guess I consider
myself an AI technologist
and researcher foremost.
I've been a professor for most
of my professional career.
And before taking
the sabbatical,
I've been Director
of Stanford AI lab.
And here at Google, I'm Chief
Scientist of AI and machine
learning, overseeing bringing
AI technology to the enterprise
world through Google Cloud.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's great.
And in terms of doing
the work that you're
doing at Google Cloud,
what are some of the things
that as a chief
scientist do you do?
FEI-FEI LI: It's an
incredibly fascinating world.
Here, you know, Cloud is the
biggest computing platform
that humanity has ever invented
to deliver computing service
to people and businesses.
So on this platform, our
goal is to really democratize
AI services and products
to as many businesses
and as many people as possible.
And so Google Cloud offers
a suite of AI products,
from APIs to customized models
to more close collaboration
and partnership
services to really try
to enable businesses to
solve their critical problem
through AI solutions.
We also in the
meantime advance AI
technology, because as
you get close to solving
real-world problems,
new challenges arise,
and that inspires the
development of new AI
technology.
And we work closely with
Google's AI research
and development teams
throughout the entire company
to advance AI as well.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
And I know that there was
recent release of, like, AutoML,
and there's been
the advancements
with TPUs and TensorFlow.
What are some of the things that
you've seen, especially from,
like, applied AI, that you
think are very relevant in terms
of what's important for
businesses to be aware of?
FEI-FEI LI: Yeah, so
that's a great question.
I want to first take
AutoML as an example
because that's a product that
really, truly excites me.
It bears the meaning and
mission of democratizing AI
beautifully.
We see that more
and more business
would like to use
AI as a service
to improve their products.
And much of the power comes into
making predictions and doing
smart analytics of the
data the business have.
But it used to be,
you know, still
is true that AI is a
pretty technical field.
It's also young enough
that not every business
has the kind of AI talent
that Stanford or Google has.
So the barrier of
entry is pretty high.
So we've been thinking about how
to lower the barrier of entry
for businesses to use AI.
So let's take image
as an example.
If you are a real
estate company,
maybe you want to tag different
kind of houses or rooms.
If you are a retail
clothing company,
you want to take an
image and tag shoes
or different kind of
shoes or clothings.
If you are a nonprofit
tracking wild animals,
you would like to
take photos and tag
leopards versus giraffe.
So there's a lot of need
for this kind of AI work.
Well, one way to
solve the problem
is through what we call APIs.
These are pre-trained model
that Google engineers have
built that work fantastically,
and companies can just
upload their images and get,
say, a label from the pictures
using these API models.
But there's one thing that
API doesn't do for you,
which is customization.
The API results come
from a pre-trained model
that has a pre-designed
set of labels.
It's a lot of labels,
thousands of labels,
but it's still pre-designed.
But if you truly cares about
just tracking wild animals
or cares about
satellite imagery,
you're now in the realm of
a need for customization.
And in fact, lots and lots
of businesses and people
need customization and they
don't have the capacity
to do it from data curation all
the way to creating the model.
So we saw that as a
important opportunity
and created this new
product called AutoML,
starting from image
understanding or image tagging.
That it's really
almost a plug-and-play
that customers can give us their
data that they want to label,
and we built a specific
customized model for them
to use.
I'm not going to get
into the details,
but the model is built on some
of the cutting-edge Google AI
technology.
MELANIE WARRICK: This must
be really exciting for you,
especially considering I know
you started out researching
around computer
vision, and to see
where it has gone from when you
started to where we are now,
and how it's being
more democratized,
as it's being more accessible.
And I know you are one of the
inventors of ImageNet, which
is this well-known
competition that
was really pivotal in the
advancement of computer
vision, which came
to a close last year.
And one of the
questions I wanted
to ask you is just
sort of a sideline
is, how do you feel
seeing something
that you built that helped
advance a space that
matters so much to you, how do
you feel now that it's closed?
What does that mean to you?
FEI-FEI LI: So first of all,
I think ImageNet is generally
a group effort.
So many of my
colleagues, students
are part of the core
creation team of ImageNet.
And as a team, we
are very proud.
We're proud that ImageNet has
made a contribution, computer
vision.
It is one of the
driving forces of what
we see as the deep
learning revolution.
And closing down the competition
in the academic world
is really just the
beginning of a new chapter.
First of all, Kaggle is
now hosting ImageNet.
So the democratization
of ImageNet data
and this competition
itself lives on,
and it's reaching
to more developers.
It's also a sign
of the progress.
Scientific discovery
and innovation
is always built upon the
continuous renewal of ideas.
And ImageNet served a
important historical purpose.
When we decided to finish
the academic competition,
we recognized the field is
ready to embrace new ideas.
So that's where we are
with computer vision
and machine learning.
MARK MANDEL: For those
people who aren't as familiar
with, say, ImageNet, can
you explain a little bit
about what that is,
and also the transition
that it's gone through?
You said it's gone
into Kaggle now.
FEI-FEI LI: So ImageNet
was a project my students,
collaborator, and I
did starting 2007.
The end product by 2009 is
a gigantic image data set
of 15 million images labeled
over 22,000 categories
of objects and real
world objects and things
and concepts, and publicly
released to the world of AI
research and education.
It was-- the goal of making
ImageNet was to reboot machine
learning research and
rethink the relationship
between algorithm and data.
It was built at
the time that data
was not as recognized the
key ingredient of AI systems.
ImageNet's contribution,
I think part of it
is because of that it enabled
the family of algorithms
called neural network
to show its potential.
And because of that
effort, we think
it was important to encourage
the academic and research
community to benchmark their
algorithms on ImageNet.
So we created the ImageNet
competition started in 2009.
Actually, starting in 2010.
And that competition
served as a good platform
for international
teams to benchmark
the progress we're making
in computer vision.
And the transition in
2017 is that we recognize,
just as I said before,
we've come a long way.
The problem that
ImageNet set out
to do-- object,
classification, and detection--
is I wouldn't call
largely solved,
but is made so much
progress that we
need to create a space for
new problems and new ideas.
MELANIE WARRICK: To inspire
new things, new ways
to solve these types of
problems versus solve different
problems.
FEI-FEI LI: Exactly.
That's why we transitioned it
from a academic competition
to a Kaggle data set.
MELANIE WARRICK:
So in terms of AI,
I've seen you talk about
how you like to emphasize
that it's not artificial.
Why the emphasis that
it's not artificial?
And is this related to,
also, in reaction to AI hype?
Do you have any thoughts around
that that you'd want to share?
FEI-FEI LI: Yes.
I now tend to say that I share
with my students and colleagues
that the field of AI is
nothing but artificial.
And what I really mean is that
this is a deeply, deeply human
pursuit, because
AI as a technology
is going to influence and
impact our human lives
and human society in
very profound ways.
And as technologists, I
think it's really important
to recognize that.
Humanity has never created
a technology that resemble
ourselves as much as AI does.
And of course, part
of ourselves is
being able to function with
the level of logical reasoning
and computation.
But part of being human
is also recognizing
the social relationships, the
emotion, the wanting to do good
and all that.
And since AI as a technology
is so powerful and impacting
so many different
sectors of the world,
we want to recognize
its human impact,
and also prepare ourselves
to AI's human impact.
MELANIE WARRICK: So off
of that human impact
and also off of what you
were saying about ImageNet
and trying to look into the
next phase of what research
would look like,
I know you've also
talked about the
new goalposts being
around natural
conversation, collaboration,
emotional perception.
What do you think in terms
of where things are going?
And what types of
benchmarks are needed
for those types of goals?
FEI-FEI LI: Yeah,
that's a good question.
I think that if you look at the
complexity and the intricacy
of human intelligence, being
able to classify or group
concepts is only one of them.
That's what mostly
what ImageNet did.
But whether it's our visual
ability or our navigation
ability or our natural
language communication
ability or comprehension,
reasoning, emotion,
humans are really complex.
So I think in order to think
about the next step of AI
it's really important to
go beyond the simple tasks
that we are starting
to excel at,
but to recognize the
complexity of intelligence.
There are already some
interesting budding research.
Google and many other
groups are looking deeply
at things like, for example,
natural language dialogue.
For me that's a very
interesting area
where you go beyond just
labeling parts of sentences
to actually enabling a
machine-human dialogue
in meaningful ways.
For vision, starting to
tell the story of a picture,
starting to reason
on the picture,
starting to understand the
events, the human activities,
the object functions, and all
those would be the next step.
MELANIE WARRICK: And take
what we've excelled at
and do what you've been
talking about in terms
of democratizing it and making
it accessible for people
who use it.
So your research,
one of the areas
that you've been
focused on lately
is more in the health sector.
Can you tell us
a little bit more
about what are
some of the things
that you're exploring
in that space?
FEI-FEI LI: Right.
So you're referring to
some of my collaborations
with Stanford School of Medicine
and also Stanford Children's
Hospital and adult hospital.
So a few years ago we thought
deeply about AI transformation,
and one of the most
exciting transformation
that everybody hears about
is self-driving cars.
And this is the
result of advances
from sensing technology
to perception technology
to machine learning
technology and all that.
And then we recognize
that there is actually
a parallel opportunity
in health care
that has more analogy
to self-driving car
than most people recognize.
It's really about
the space of care,
is the how do we enable care
in a more effective way.
For example, in hospitals there
is a lot of things going on,
and work could be
more efficient.
Errors should be avoided.
Patients can be
monitored further.
Or in elder homes, can we
enable more intelligent ambient
sensing and machine
learning to help
families and clinicians to
take care of our elders,
and all that.
And we start to recognize, wow,
this is the kind of technology
that's needed in these
potential services,
is very similar to
self-driving cars.
It uses smart sensors
to gather information
from the environment.
And then back end, it uses
computer vision and machine
learning techniques to
recognize activities
and to make decisions.
So we started to collaborate
with Stanford Hospital and also
a senior home facility
in San Francisco
to explore how we can use AI to
help avoid health care workflow
errors or to help aging seniors,
especially early detection
of dementia and all that.
And a specific
example is a product
we're doing with Lucile
Packard Hospital at Stanford
where we put smart sensors or
depth sensors in the hospital
unit to help doctors and nurses
monitor their hand hygiene
practice.
It turned out the
lack of hand hygiene
or hospital-acquired
infection is
one of the leading killers
of our patients in hospitals.
It kills more people than
car accidents per year.
And how do we continuously
monitor the behavior
of proper hand hygiene
practice is actually
a very difficult task.
And it's expensive to deploy
people to watch people.
And that is very sparse.
It introduces bias.
So we thought, wow, the
same kind of depth sensor
self-driving car uses
to watch the pedestrians
and cars on the road
could be actually put
into the hospitals.
So we installed
these smart sensors
that are also
privacy preserving,
and use computer vision
technology in the back end
to be able to continuously
monitor and observe
hand hygiene practice
in the hospital unit.
And that was one of the first
kind ever done in that way.
And we're very excited to see
some initial results showing
that a automatic
observing system using AI
does as good, even better
actually than human observers,
but it doesn't get tired.
It's not biased and all that.
MELANIE WARRICK:
That would be great.
And this was a recent
implementation,
so the results haven't
come back just yet.
FEI-FEI LI: We actually, it's
in submission to a publication.
MELANIE WARRICK: Got it.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
Nice.
I'd love to take a slightly
different tack here.
This work, it sounds fantastic.
But you've been in the AI
and machine learning industry
for a really long time and
you've watched it grow,
and you were talking a bit
about barriers to entry
and, like, the speed at
which it's progressing.
If people are coming in new to
machine learning and AI now,
and they're interested
in getting involved,
where should they
go, what should they
do, what path do you
think they should take?
FEI-FEI LI: Yeah, good question.
I get that a lot as a professor.
So I think it depends on
what you're interested in.
If you are interested in
machine learning as a research,
then I think it's important to
get involved in the research
projects that, I assume
that's when you have already
some technical background.
If you're interested in the
machine learning implementation
and software engineering,
there is already
a lot of online courses.
And you know,
Google's TensorFlow
and the TensorFlow
community has a lot
of materials that
can help to get
your hands on to the
coding and software
engineering of the site.
If you're interested in using
machine learning as a way
to create interesting startups,
entrepreneurial opportunities,
start thinking about the pain
points of different businesses
and products, and find
areas where using smart data
analytics or machine
learning techniques can help
solve a pain point.
But machine learning and
AI is not just technical.
That goes back to
my original point.
There is actually a lot of
related areas, machine learning
and policy, right?
Or AI and education,
AI for sustainability,
AI for economics.
There's a lot of
now new areas that
are at the cross-section of AI
technology and human impact.
So a lot of people, even
without technical background,
can get involved and contribute.
MELANIE WARRICK:
You know, I know
that you get asked
a lot about the AI,
sort of what are the
bigger challenges.
And you spearhead efforts
around diversity inclusion,
and you have this wonderful
organization, AI For All.
Can you tell us a little bit
about that and what it does?
FEI-FEI LI: Yes.
So AI is a field that largely
stemmed from computer science.
And I think it's
pretty obvious by now
that the general field of
computer science and AI
has a critical issue
of lack of diversity.
We lack women.
We lack underrepresented
minority.
All the publicly released data,
whether it's Silicon Valley
companies or academia, we're
seeing a very small percentage
of women, and even
smaller percentage
of underrepresented
minority in this field.
And I think that is a
pity, because involving
more diversity would
make our field better.
And we talk about
several reasons.
One is for economic
and labor reason.
We need more and
more CS AI talents,
and we need to tap
into all walks of life.
It's also an innovation
creativity reason
that when diverse group
of people coming together,
solutions and ideas
are more innovative.
And it's also a fairness
and justice reason.
When we want a technology
to resemble or to represent
the values of our
collective society,
we want all walks of
life to be involved
in developing and creating it.
For these three reasons, at
Stanford about four years ago,
we started this program to
encourage diversity group
of high school
students to participate
in the study and early
hands-on research of AI.
And we created this program
called Stanford AI Lab Outreach
Summer.
And at Stanford we were
focusing on high school girls
around 10th grade,
and we bring them
on campus for two to
three weeks in the summer,
and they study AI.
But also, they study AI
and its human mission
and human-centered impact.
And that has been very,
luckily, successful.
So we decided in
2017 to expand it
to a national
nonprofit organization.
We call it AI For All
to really replicate
the Stanford model and create
summer camps nationwide.
And so we started with
Berkeley last year,
where they reached out
to low-income families
and students.
And I'm focusing on robotics.
2017 we're expanding
to Princeton
to underrepresented racial
minority students to study AI
and policy.
We are expanding
to CMU this year
as well to reach out
to rural population.
And so we're expanding to
six different sites 2018,
and we'll continue this effort.
MELANIE WARRICK: And we plan
to include in our show notes,
too, ways for people
to link in and find out
how to get involved.
I want to make sure,
is there anything else
that you wanted to share
or talk about, you know,
from AI, from the research,
from recommendations for people
to think about how
they get involved,
how they can get into the space?
FEI-FEI LI: AI is
incredibly exciting.
I guess I'm biased, but being
a AI technologist and also
educator for 20
years, I think seeing
this field has grown from
a niche academic field
to become one of
the biggest drivers
of the fourth
Industrial Revolution
is really extremely
exciting and rewarding.
And in this process I think
we are just at the beginning,
even though we hear a lot about
AI and its progress so far.
But we really are just seeing
the beginning of the power
of this technology.
So I would love to see more
people getting involved,
and different parts of
the world, technologies,
technologists,
humanists, policymakers,
social scientists, you
know, lawmakers all
come together and have deeper
and multi-way dialogue,
and to design this
technology, and also guide
the impact of this technology.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Great, thank you.
FEI-FEI LI: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
thank you so much.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thank
you again, Dr. Fei-Fei Li.
We are really
grateful that you were
able to come on and talk
to us about your work, what
your research is, what
your experience was,
how you felt about ImageNet.
All of it was wonderful.
And if anything, there were
so many other questions
we still wanted to ask, but
we were limited on time.
So we worked with what we had.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
But you're welcome
back any time.
MELANIE WARRICK: Definitely.
MARK MANDEL: Definitely.
So why don't we move on to
our question of the week?
And I'm going to
ask you, Melanie.
MELANIE WARRICK: Sure.
MARK MANDEL: So I'm
interested in AI and ML--
in theory-- and I would
like to learn more.
[LAUGHTER]
Where can I go?
MELANIE WARRICK: You mean I
haven't beat it over your head
enough in this podcast?
So there's a couple
of resources,
and we'll definitely add
those in the show notes.
And I'll probably come up with
some more when we post this.
But one in particular
that comes to mind
is most people will talk
about, Andrew Ng famously
has a Coursera course
that's out there that many
will go to on a regular
basis when they are initially
starting out.
MARK MANDEL: I've
done half of that.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: Sweet.
Good job.
Maybe you'll get to the
other half at this point.
MARK MANDEL: Maybe.
MELANIE WARRICK: Fast.ai
is also a group out there
that has some wonderful
content, especially in terms
of deep learning and just
helping to really break down
the basics around
some of the math
and the machine
learning in general.
Google just launched
a course on Coursera.
It's saying how Google
does machine learning.
So we will also include
that in our show notes.
But there's definitely
a number of resources.
These are some key
ones that come to mind.
And yeah, we'll make sure
we share what we have.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
It looks like enrollment for the
Google one starts on March 12.
MELANIE WARRICK: Good point.
All right, well, I think
that's it for this week.
And anything coming up for you?
I don't think you've
talked about anything
that you have this month.
MARK MANDEL: No, GDC.
It's all GDC all the time.
MELANIE WARRICK:
That's all you do.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
it's all I do.
Yep.
So come say hello.
I'll be at the booth.
I won't be at the developer day,
but there's a Google developer
day that's going to talk about
a bunch of different Google
products on the Monday.
But I'll be at the booth various
times from Wednesday to Friday.
We're sponsoring Women
in Games International,
so I'll be at that
party as well.
That's probably about
it for the moment.
I'm sure I'll have some
more stuff coming up.
MELANIE WARRICK: Awesome.
Well, Happy International
Women's Day a day
early since we'll be
releasing this on the 7th.
And I hope everybody out
there has a good one.
MARK MANDEL: Yes, absolutely.
MELANIE WARRICK: And I think
that's it for us for this week.
MARK MANDEL: For this week.
So yeah.
Melanie, thank
you for joining me
for yet another
week on the podcast.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thanks, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Thank
you all for listening.
And we'll see you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]